♪ Yeah, okay it's Tea with Garyvee ♪
♪ Sipping in for tea ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Putting out all my shit for free ♪
♪ This is Tea with Garyvee ♪
♪ Michael make a flip ♪
- Good morning.
I am ready to rock and roll.
Good morning everybody,
good morning Dustin,
good morning, all the people in the chats.
Joel with Growing Design,
thank you for joining us.
Jokes on The World,
thank you for being here.
Thanks for everybody on
YouTube, Facebook, Twitter.
I see all of you guys in here and girls,
Virginia, Fernando, good morning.
Let's get into the show.
Actually it was a big one.
Let's get right into it.
- Good morning, good morning.
What's up?
What's up Moy?
- How are you?
- Good.
I'm Sebastian, this is Oliver.
- Nice to meet you Gary.
- Basically, (mumbles) asking you,
'cause I know that you
used to work with your dad
and we're brothers and we work together.
I wanted to know if you had any like tips
for working with family.
- And I worked with my brother
when we started VaynerMedia.
And my brother and I worked
together on VaynerSports.
Oliver, Sebastian, I
think the biggest thing
that people make the mistake
with family businesses
is a lot of things actually.
First of all, if you're
capable of loving each other
more than the money and
the fame and the respect,
that will always play out.
I genuinely believe that
above everything else,
like just truly valuing the relationships
with my brother and dad,
like more than the money
and the accolades really, really mattered.
Then the other thing is over communicating
to each other about dollars
and the kind of respect.
One of the reasons that,
my brother and I worked so well together
was my brother was more
confident and more comfortable
with me being the front
man and getting the credit
and he valued the dollars,
not more, but like he was fine with that.
And for me, I value the dollars
less than being the guy,
I wanna be the guy.
With my dad, we had more of
that friction point of like,
who's the guy?
And that made it more difficult.
But still we were kind of
able to overcome the friction.
This is just ego and respect and money.
Those are the two places
and that's why it's so hard.
Most people actually care about money
and get into fights over it.
Or they actually care about
why did you sell all that merchandise?
Was it Sebastian?
Was it Oliver?
There's that ego and then
there's the legacy of it.
It's balancing humility
and wanting credit.
There's just a lot of
like real raw emotions,
you know what I mean?
- Decision making is really tough
'cause we both have valid points.
And I never would say that
Sebastian is wrong or anything
but I would say that
when I come up with like
my point or my perspective
and he comes up with his perspective,
it's really tough to
balance out each other.
- You know what's really worked
for both of my family businesses?
Dividing and conquering.
'Cause you can't have
two cooks in the kitchen.
'Cause to your point Olive like,
it's not that you think Sebastian's wrong,
it's that by you saying it should be red
and him saying it should be blue.
Just in that small thing,
when you're passionate about your thing,
you wanna see your thing come to life.
It's not even about being right or wrong,
it's not seeing it come to life
the way you envisioned it in your brain.
- That's true.
- I really mean this like,
I think where people get caught
is they try to both do the same thing.
And I think dividing
and conquering matters.
When you have two cooks in the kitchen,
you have no cooks in the
kitchen, just friction.
For example, just cause
you guys are wearing it,
if you're doing merch, if I
was like the third brother,
I'll be like, if I was
the third older brother,
"Here's a strategy, we're
gonna make nine pieces of merch
and everybody makes
their own three pieces.
And who gives a fuck if
the fonts are different?
like, you know what I mean?
That will work better because
then merit can breathe
versus it being convoluted.
And what ends up happening
when it doesn't work
or when it does work?
When it doesn't work, you're doing this.
You're like, see it was your fucking,
even though both of your DNA is in it.
When it does work, even
though it's blended,
then both are saying, this,
and you get into that friction point.
And that's why I think
dividing and conquering
might really matters as well.
Joint decisions are
impossible for a business.
- Okay.
- Back to sports, you don't
have two quarterbacks.
You have two quarterbacks
but one on the bench.
They're not both out
there grabbing the ball.
Same with business.
There is no co-CEO, it doesn't work.
- True.
- But what you could
do is if your partners,
is divide and conquer.
You almost wanna write down every task
and then pick one person to be one A
and one person to be one B.
- Okay.
- AJ and I had a really
good rule which was
if we actually, actually couldn't get
to a joint decision
through a conversation,
I would make the final
call 'cause I was the CEO.
That was basically the punchline.
And that really worked.
And he was great at like
kind of, sticking to that.
With my dad, I really let
him work on the finances
and I kind of operated,
but it was his business and
he was used to operating.
When he would kinda try
to make a joint decision
or oppose decision or adjust my decision,
that's when a lot of friction happened,
especially with when you've
got employees underneath you.
- How long have you been working
with your brother and dad?
- My whole life, in essence.
Still to this day.
Basically every
professional day of my life,
I've been in that place.
And I'll be honest with you,
when I'm most by myself, is
when it's most enjoyable.
What I mean by that is,
in the years where my dad
was really letting me run
the business, it was great.
Vayner was really easy, AJ
really gave me that spot.
But even after he left and
went to run VaynerSports,
it was even better.
It's hard when you're
one to share the ball.
And it's not because you're
greedy or you're mean
or you're selfish.
It's that, decisions drive a business.
I have enormous conviction
and can make my decisions very quickly.
I struggle with people that
don't have that clarity.
I don't have clarity on other
people's decisions either.
I think it's divide and conquer.
What's been the biggest
friction point for you two?
What's been the biggest fight
that you've had or about what?
- It's mainly when we just
have two different opinions
or something.
We've definitely learned from
before a lot of different ways
Work together.
- To work together and stuff.
I mean obviously we still
go through our struggles.
- Of course.
- Most part, everything's
been a way better than before.
- Do you guys have a good
sense of where you are?
If I said to both of you,
between money and like the credit,
what do you guys say?
Oliver, Sebastian, if I asked you,
there's 100% for you,
money, credit, where
are you percentage-wise?
- Credit, money.
- No, I would say I was more credit but,
- But real quick, real quick on that.
It's not as simple as that.
For example, when you say credit, money,
you might be 70/30 and he might be 30/70.
And in that is the actual
unlock to your happiness.
'Cause you're not 100/0
and he's not 0/100.
But once you understand
that, it really helps.
But I'm telling you by a country mile,
the number one piece of advice I have
is don't be in a position
where you have to make joint decisions.
Divide and conquer as much as you can.
Where you have to make joint decisions,
see if you can do both.
- That sounds cool, I like that.
You see what I mean?
- Yeah.
- The more separated you are,
the more together you'll be,
If you're like, "Hey, we wanna
make this piece of content."
Just make both of your
fucking pieces of content,
like literally.
Even if they're similar.
- I got you, I got you.
- Good, good luck guys.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
See you later.
- That's a good one.
- Hey, what's up?
- What's good Richard?
Good to see you again.
- Yeah, I'm back again.
Thank you for doing this,
super happy to be here.
I'm gonna go straight to the point.
I wanted to hear your take
on a quantity versus quality
of content for consistency purposes.
My question is,
is a lot of average content
better than great content?
- Yes.
- With a lot consistency?
Yes.
- Okay.
- Here's why, who gets to decide
that it's average, Richard?
- Right, true.
- Answer the question.
It's only me who controls
like the content.
- That's it, that's where
you have it mixed up.
That's why I'm so excited.
That's why I wanted to you to answer it.
You don't get to decide,
the audience gets to decide.
And you're gonna say no
for the audience too often.
- Okay.
- Creators, artists
say no for the audience
without the audience having a look.
- That's true.
- The end.
That's why this is such
an easy question for me.
(Richard laughs)
It's an easy question.
It's just insecurity about the content.
If you know people use perfection
as a disguise to not put out.
It's actually being a cliche artist
and worrying about what people think
and having some sort of
ideology in your own head
or just judging your own self.
That's why I wanna push
everybody to put things out
'cause they will learn from
what the audience likes
instead of playing the game
of life in their own head.
- Okay, true.
As you advocate us to do
two, three poses daily.
So I try to honor that flow,
but I find it difficult sometimes
'cause I wanna do above average packaging.
- But you are making
that up in your own mind.
Like that's my concern.
My concern is that,
I don't know if you even know yet,
if you haven't put out 100 things,
you don't even really know.
Your below average might be above average.
You just might be that talented.
Or you may put out something
that's below average
but you read the comments
and you get an insight
which makes your next piece
of content way better.
Most people do not respect the audience.
It's a very interesting insight.
I would argue that, what
really works for me,
is I overly respect the audience.
All I'm doing is like looking
at the comments right now
while I'm on with you,
from Ontar Goodwin and Kareem Elrashidi
and Sam Reed and Mark Martinez,
I'm watching even when I'm creating.
They're always right, we're never right.
We might've been right
and then it plays out,
but we don't know if we're right
or wrong until it goes out.
And no content ruins you.
People are like, "Oh, if I put this out,
people are gonna think I'm
whack and then I have no shots."
Just doesn't work that way.
You know which wack fucking
songs the Beatles put out?
More than people realize.
You like that right?
- Yeah, it's true.
- It's a liberator.
- It makes me realize that I can do, yeah,
I don't have to like
dwell on little things
and just go ahead and post it.
- You also don't know.
You need to post it to
see if you're right.
I put on shit sometimes,
I'm like this is gonna suck and it sucks.
I'm like, yeah, I know my shit.
When I write up WineText,
and I write it, sometimes
I'm like, this is fire.
It's gonna sell out in a minute.
And then when it doesn't do well,
I'm like, oh my shit, I was right.
Sometimes I'm like,
shit flies out in an hour, all sold out.
And I'm like, okay that taught me,
you got to learn.
- Okay, cool.
I have a one quick question.
- Go.
- You always say also, be
giving to do jobs, jobs, jobs
and I wanted to see, with you,
does it make sense to provide,
I'm a producer, DJ, sound engineer,
does it make sense to provide
my creations to people
who I still got emails,
maybe even if we don't
necessarily still talk.
It could be people who worked
with maybe the Rihanna's
or other street dancers
and stuff like that.
But just to reach them and be like,
"Hey, I got this,
I was thinking about you,
I think this makes sense."
- Yes, but you know that
they're doing more for you
than you're doing for them.
When you're Rihanna, if they're
putting in your fucking,
if they're taking your
productions, that's huge for you.
What would be better in my opinion,
is to go to SoundCloud
or Instagram or Tik Tok
and find people that are
emerging, that really need it.
Then you're really giving.
Because when you're giving
to Rihanna or Beyonce,
you're not giving, they're putting you on.
- Okay, I get that.
All right bro.
- Thank you.
You got it.
- Peace.
People often wanna give to
people that when they receive it,
it actually is more valuable to you.
And people wanna give
me things all the time.
"GaryVee, I made this song for you,
for your Tea with Garyvee."
The reality is we've had two theme songs
on Tea with Garyvee.
The second one, that's been good.
But a lot of people made those things
and a lot of times they're
making it for their benefit.
And that's great.
And sometimes the person will say yes
but please recognize you're not giving,
you're asking in that scenario.
Exposure at that level is worth way more
than the production value
of that thing, just always.
Especially in a world where there's
unlimited people offering that production.
Keep it going.
Hey Gary.
- Hey Gary.
How you doing?
- Hi guys.
I'm doing well, how are you?
- So good, super grateful to be here.
Thank you so much for having us.
- Thanks Pili.
What's cooking?
- We're here in Westfield,
we're not too far from you.
- Super close.
- Yes sir, yes sir.
I love that.
- Super grateful.
Pili's been listen to you for a while.
I jumped on, started listening
to you back in December
and that gotta say, what you say works.
- Yeah, everything.
- We have our podcast,
Jason and Pili project,
We've had some great guests come on
by just DM them through Instagram
and all of a sudden they're
replying, just shocking.
People are like, "How'd you get them on?"
I was like, "GaryVee said DM them."
And I said I'll try that.
People come on.
Our goal this year was we were working
to get really more live speaking going.
That's gonna now get
sidelined for a long time.
We did hear you say, start a live show
to somebody about a week ago.
We started a live show every day at noon,
Second Cup of Coffee
with Jason and Pili Live
and that's been going well.
Across our platforms we're getting good,
private feedback from people.
People reach out on the sideline
but we're not finding a way
to get like active
engagement in the platforms.
- You're getting private
messages at a high level
but you're not getting as
many comments and likes
and shares on the actual content?
Correct.
- Yes.
- What do you want the most of?
Let's go very tactical
here to bring people value.
When you say engagement, in order,
on which platform?
And then before we go into that,
what's the content that
you're talking about?
- Our podcast is about
providing fulfillment.
Really just pushing to prove
that we can improve mental fortitude,
grow wealth and improve health.
- It has a foundation in real estate.
We are a large multifamily providers.
- Understood.
Are you getting a lot of private things,
because people are getting
into a mindset thing
and they're being honest with you on DM
that they may feel uncomfortable
in the comment section?
Or asking you more direct
questions financially
of how to become a
multifamily kind of executer?
You're just finding more in that realm.
- I get a lot in the fitness side.
I do a lot of crazy challenges
on the fitness side.
I'm running like 465 miles this month.
We get a lot of people
reach out from that.
- But private.
- Sorry.
Privately or publicly?
- Privately, yeah.
- It's funny, I get way
more private messages
than I get them with my engagement.
And I get a shitload of engagement
that just means I get a fuck
load of private messages.
Let's break this down.
If I went very literal,
because I don't do this often,
so I think this will help a lot of people.
And you guys have clearly shown to me
that you've listened to tactics
which have brought you benefits.
So I really wanna go tactical.
When you say engagement, which
platform and what action?
- Facebook and YouTube
would be the prime tool
that we we try and build out further.
- And what (mumbles) you looking for?
When you say engagement,
are you looking for comments and likes?
Or if you're talking
about these two platforms,
are you talking about more subscribers?
- YouTube would be subscribers,
Facebook would be engagement
to make sure that we're providing content
that's been benefiting the listeners.
'Cause right now, we're
getting the private feedback
but we're not getting on the platforms.
We're not sure if our
content is giving them,
- You're getting the feedback.
- Yeah, just not,
- Jason, you said to me,
you're looking for the feedback
to make sure that you're
providing the right value.
But you are getting the feedback.
What you're actually saying,
which is very fine, no problem at all,
"Hey, we'd like to get more of it publicly
because that in itself helps us more.
More people see it,
it builds more momentum."
You're not looking to help them,
you're looking to help yourself.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
This is why I wanna break it down.
(mumbles)
For me, I'm able to
really create more content
seven out of 10 times
because of the private messages'
more than the comments.
Because people will go
a level deeper private.
And I'm like, there's something there.
Shit, rich kids are sad.
I need to talk about entitlement.
Nobody's leaving a comment like,
"Gary that's me, I'm a rich kid.
I'm a piece of shit.
I take all my money from my parents
but I may pretend I earned it, I suck ."
People don't do that.
They go and do it in DM.
And so I think that,
what you're talking
about a little bit more
is things that benefit you, which is fine.
More comments, more shares,
more likes, you should.
I genuinely believe it's
very hard to be selfless
unless you have a level of selfishness.
You should have your own
ambitious wants and needs.
It's not that you want more feedback
to make sure you're doing the right thing,
'cause you're getting that.
It's that you're trying to
grow, which is super fine.
Believe it or not, the
answer is really wild.
It's called asking.
One of the things that really works
is literally asking.
For example, even though I
can bring it up 100 times,
none of these fuckers are
signing up for WineText.
Thank you.
(mumbles)
I don't know if you drink (mumbles) water
but today is a crazy one.
So get ready, it's gonna go fast.
- 30 days (mumbles) and
we got three little kids
at the back who are being quiet (mumbles).
- But I think you need to ask.
I think you should make a
nice little piece of content
at the end of all your content,
it basically says, "Hey,
it would mean a lot."
But you should film something and be like,
"Hey, we're really hustling out here.
It would mean a lot to
us if you left a comment
and shared this and liked and subscribed."
The ask.
The right hook of the job.
Most people are just not asking.
It's literally just asking both in video,
audio written and visual forum.
I'm being dead serious.
- Good amount of content
and so maybe we're missing
just really the end cap to it.
- You know what I did with Wine Library TV
that completely exploded back in the day
when I wanted that?
I created something called
the question of the day.
Every episode, they might be 1000 of them,
maybe 950 after I invented it,
was like, "All right, time
for the question today.
Which (mumbles) did you drink?
And then it got people to practice.
Question a day.
I do its still now,
tag one person that you think
will get value out of this.
It's called the ask.
Okay.
- Got it.
- You're providing
value for your audience.
You're more than in a position to ask.
Not demand,
not say, "If you don't leave a
comment, you get kicked out."
It's a very simple ask.
(mumbles)
- we got kids running
around, they've been quiet.
(mumbles)
So super appreciate yourself.
I don't have any crazy gifts for you.
We appreciate your content
but I do ask 10 minutes on our podcast
somewhere in the future?
- Yes, somewhere in the
future, I'm in for that.
Only 'cause this little cutie.
This is the young one.
- All right, thanks guys.
Take care.
- This is how
I try to get people on.
- I get it, I'm sure.
Thank you.
- Sucked when I was a baby.
I respect it.
You're welcome, see you later.
- See you Gary.
- Big (mumbles) today on WineText.
Very simply, simple ask, based on that.
That's gonna matter.
If you buy three bottles of wine a month,
in any shape or form,
Publix, Trader Joe's,
Costco, Wine.com,
if you buy three bottles of wine a month,
please, please, please,
please stop right now,
go to winetext.com,
sign up, it takes two minutes.
Take a photo, put it on Twitter.
Let me retweet you that you did it.
It would mean a lot to me.
Let's keep it going.
- Hey Gary, this is exciting.
- Well this is huge.
The NCAA board announced
it supports a rule change
that would allow student athletes
to seek compensation for
third party endorsement
both related and separate from athletics,
starting in 2020.
It also supports compensation
for other opportunities
like social media, wow.
VaynerSports just changed.
- Gary, can you hear us?
- Yeah.
(mumbles)
- I could hear you.
Breaking news out of the NCAA
about compensating kids
that play collegiate sports
which I think will really change
VaynerSports.
Okay, let's rock and roll.
- Hi Gary, I've always wanted to meet you.
Thank you.
- I'm probably like,
everywhere I'm in my life
right now, is because of you.
- Thank you.
It's not true, good news.
It's 'cause of you, you took action.
But I appreciate, I'll take the assist.
I'll John Stockton for Karl Malone.
Go ahead.
- I tried eBay flipping like three times,
failed every time.
I tried crypto investing and Amazon FBA
and now I have a freelance business.
And I just got to quit my job
at Walmart three months ago.
- Good for you.
- My question is, when should
I hire my first employee
'cause I wanna grow beyond just,
The second you can afford it.
- A one man band.
Okay.
- Can you afford it now?
- I don't know.
- Let's define affording.
As long as you don't spend money,
do you have enough money
to get an employee?
- Not like full time,
- So then get part time.
- At least a little bit, yeah.
- Then you should do it.
- Okay.
- The sooner you learn
what it feels like to
employ someone, the better.
So even if you got somebody
for 10 hours a week,
that's learnings for you.
That's why it's awesome.
If you pay the minimum wage or
something small, you're set.
Jared, you know where
people get really caught?
They're willing to pay
for college and to learn.
But then in real life,
they're not willing to
pay to actually learn.
You paying somebody,
is gonna teach you how
to be a boss of somebody
and it's a much better
deal than a college diploma
that talks about being
the boss of somebody.
- That's kinda interesting
that you say that,
'cause I did martial arts for 12 years
and I took minimum wage from the guy.
So I actually ended up losing money
'cause I did pay for
teaching certificates.
And I did run like the demo
team for awhile and teaching
and planning curriculum
and running instructor.
That one thing you said, what was it like?
Three nines is not as good as
like 60 sixes or something.
Remember that?
I kinda feel smart 'cause I learned that
before you put that out.
- Brother, you're plenty
of smart, don't worry.
I don't get to make the rules.
I get to share my thoughts
and things I've learned.
Don't put my advice on a
pedestal but know this,
you hiring somebody
even for 10 hours a week
is a monster win.
- Okay.
- I'm just gonna use 10 bucks an hour.
That 100 bucks a week is teaching,
you're getting paid to learn to learn.
And then if she or he
is bringing you value,
I mean this is a fucking huge win.
People are very confused out here brother.
People are willing to pay to learn
through courses and degrees and schools,
and then they don't learn by paying
to do things in their actual business.
I basically think everything
I'm doing is learning
and if I get the output that I paid for,
then that's like the bonus.
- Okay.
- I want the context, I want the reps.
- That makes sense to me.
- Now all of a sudden,
you can see why you would
hire somebody earlier
'cause now it's a
different value proposition
than am I gonna get my return on my money?
It doesn't matter if you do.
Now you're learning something
which is gonna help you longterm
because you're so young.
- Yeah, I'm only 21.
I'm like a baby.
- I love you brother,
You are a super baby.
Keep pushing.
Keep thinking that way.
Keep thinking like your
martial arts thing.
Keep remembering this
moment when we talked.
Investing in something
that brings you learnings
is always (mumbles).
- Always better.
Especially better than
learning it on paper
or from somebody else.
Hearing about it 10 times
is way less valuable
than doing it once.
- Okay.
I've kinda been frustrated lately
'cause I took on like way too much work.
- Yeah man, it's time to fucking delegate.
- The 12 hours a day is
just too much for me.
- I respect it, by the way,
I love you for saying that.
For me, it's not because I got adrenaline
in a different way.
And for you, if seven hours is too much,
bro there's no level of money,
there's no level of success
that is more important
than happiness and balance.
I love you for that.
- Thank you.
- Notice when I was listening to you,
I was like, "Don't take
all my stuff literal."
Take my macro literal.
You need to be happy.
If six hours is good for you, well great,
then that's what it's gonna be.
- Yeah.
I did see that.
'Cause I saw my work when I was doing,
you read about six by
the way, lucky guess.
When I was working only six a day,
it was getting done faster.
And so when I was working 12,
I got this came up with six,
- You're tired.
One thing to look into
is how much do you love what you're doing
versus you think it's making you money.
Because one thing I
noticed is 12 is easier
when you fucking addicted to it.
- I agree.
'Cause I video edit, that's my thing.
It's not a 12-hour a day thing,
but it's not a zero either.
- I love that.
It's something in the middle.
- Brother, I love that.
I love it, You're in such a great spot.
At 21 to have that knowledge,
to have this framework.
Keep testing, do different shit.
I like where you're going bro.
- I see some people wanna get hired.
- I'm sure.
Why don't we put your
social handle up here.
Everyone DM Jared, if you wanna get hired.
What are you hiring for?
- I need a video editor for,
right now, it's just Instagram captions,
helping me spell check
'cause I suck at writing.
- There're (mumbles) software too.
Let Dustin put you in touch
with some of our team.
We're using some software too.
And then you can have somebody,
- Is it Rev?
Yeah, I think it is.
- Yeah, it is.
- Yeah, that's what I use.
- Good to ask (mumbles)
somebody on the post.
- Dustin put his actual handle.
- Well, thank you, this means a lot to me.
- Do you have Instagram
so people can DM you?
- I do but I don't use it.
- What about an email?
- Yeah, an email.
- Okay, what's your email?
- It's a pacificbusinessyt@gmail.com.
Do you want me to write
it in the chat for Dustin?
I think that is pretty smart.
- Okay.
Pacific, business, Y T
for YouTube, @gmail.com,
pacificbusinessyt@gmail.com.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- I'm gonna be busy reading emails today.
That's okay though.
- I think you are.
What are you looking to hire?
Real quick.
Let's take it down, I gotta move on.
- Either someone to help with captions
or someone to help cut
down gameplay live streams.
One of those two.
- Awesome.
Thanks Gary, it means a lot.
- Take care brother.
- Happy to do a brother, keep pushing.
Nice kid.
Let's keep this going.
♪ Let's keep this going ♪
Let's keep it going.
- Hi.
- Hi Natasha.
- Thank you so much for having me.
Can you hear me okay?
- Perfectly.
I am the child of an immigrant as well.
I instantly connected
with you and your story
and the way you deliver messages,
just is exactly how my
dad delivers messages.
The way you deliver everything is perfect.
I'll get into this, I'll
give you some context.
I am a creative and I started
out just doing craft fairs
and I honestly was supposed
to just kinda be like up for fun,
on the side, hobby,
extra income type thing.
Then I ended up loving it.
I then hopped on Etsy back in December.
Didn't really get any traction off Etsy.
Then I started a Tik Tok, thanks to you.
I started Tik Tok and
had a video go viral.
I'm (mumbles) city and so I
painted a custom chiefs jacket.
That video on Tik Tok went viral,
viral for me.
By not a long shot,
not Charlie or whoever.
I think it got like 40, 50,000 views.
And I was like, Whoa.
And then Etsy started like,
I was like, holy cow, what
the heck just happened?
- What happened is, you started executing
the things I talk about every day.
- 100%, yeah.
I executed what you said
and it did really well.
And I ended up popping off Etsy
because they take obviously
a portion of your fees
and I felt like if I'm
driving my own sales,
through what you're teaching you to do,
why should I give them
a portion of my money?
So I ended up creating my own website.
Things were a little slow at first.
Then I had another video go viral,
I hit 1.4 million views, which was insane.
Again my website,
the following week, Shonda Rhimes ended up
sharing one of my art pieces
on her Instagram feed.
Then it was like, again,
I tagged her, just like you
had instructed people to do.
I tagged her, it was a
Grey's Anatomy theme post.
Tagged her, she reposted
it and it was insane.
Off of that, this is
obviously very new to me.
I have had several like
influencers, lifestyle bloggers,
message me, wanting to get
like some free product,
a free jacket, free stickers, free art,
all this stuff that I make.
- Free stickers?
Free stickers excites me.
- What was that?
- Free stickers excites me.
That's low cost for
you, for good exposure.
Free stickers, yes.
Free fucking jackets,
Only if they promise to post
it and they're real big.
- Okay.
- There's no secret
math, there's no formula.
You have to go on intuition.
You should audit them,
see how engaged our audience really is.
Maybe FaceTime them for two minutes.
Maybe get a real connection.
Free stickers all day.
It's just cheap.
They put on their laptop or they share it.
Even if they don't share it,
let them have it around their life.
They are people that have influence.
It's just value exchange.
If you decide somebody's
worth of free jacket
and that's right for
you, then do that too.
Influencer marketing will work for you.
It's not a requirement.
But if you have something as
low cost as free stickers,
I'm really into that.
- Okay.
Stickers and then my art prints those are,
- You know what you need to do though,
when you send something to somebody
and nothing good happens, you can't dwell.
You have to look at it at the macro.
It's kinda like the Tik Tok viral posts.
If you gave up after the first
nine that only got 12 views
and said Gary's an idiot,
you would have never gotten to the time
when the video went viral.
Same with influencers.
If you give up after like,
"Fucking Sarah, fuck her."
If you do that, you're finished.
You need to be like Sarah
sucked, Rick sucked,
Johnny sucked, Gena sucked,
Stevie sucked, Ricky sucked.
Oh my God, Amanda changed my life.
- Okay.
- Got it?
- Yeah.
- People get emotional.
What was that?
They're like, "Fucking
Sally ripped me off.
All her followers are fake I bet."
Even if they posted and
nothing good happened,
you're like, "Fuck."
People get emotional.
There's no, fucking crying
or emotion in business.
- Yeah.
I had like 12 videos that
got literally eight views.
So if I had stopped, I
wouldn't have had any success.
- That's right.
- Another quick question.
I had had an idea to do
Instagram lives with my followers
one-on-one basically like this,
but teaching them digital
art on their iPads.
I have a business mentor
and they kind of kibosh it.
They're like, "No, you need to charge.
You need to charge for that."
Doing maybe like a 20
to 30 minute session.
- Your business mentor is a sales person.
- Okay.
- I am a marketer and brander.
I don't agree and I know
you know that already.
- I knew instantly, I was
like, Gary's not gonna agree.
I don't necessarily agree but,
- Good news, we won, two to one.
- Yeah, true.
The question though, is
there ever a time or,
- Of course.
- That I can charge for that or something?
- Yes, when you desperately need to.
- Okay.
- You know what the goal is though?
- What's that?
- To never desperately need to.
- Yeah.
And I don't desperately need to.
- Correct.
'Cause by the way, do you
know what's gonna happen?
You're gonna build a fucking community
that's gonna buy your other shit.
- Okay.
- Your business mentor's transactional.
- Your business mentor's 101.
- Okay.
- If your business mentor is getting paid,
you may wanna reconsider it.
- Okay, alright.
I listen to your podcast
24/7 and I implement
and I've turned so many
other people onto it too.
- You've implemented my free advice
and a lot of good things have happened.
- Yeah.
- You're paying for bad advice,
I'd like to see what the ROI of that is.
- Yeah, so true.
Very true.
I think you're 100% right.
And I knew instantly,
- I think you need to write a nice email
that says we no longer work together.
- Okay.
- That's my intuition, I could be wrong.
Maybe she or he was
bringing a lot of value.
If I heard everything you just said,
which is you're selling
things from exposure,
I would never charge transactional $29.
- Okay.
Alright, right on, right on.
- Talk to you.
- Thank you so much, Gary.
- See ya.
- Business mentors my fucking dick.
Let's keep it going.
Devin, what's good?
- Hey Gary, thanks for having me.
How are you doing?
- Got you, really good.
- Before I get to my question,
just wanna give you a quick background
on where I'm coming from.
About four years ago,
I quit my full time job
to start my own business.
I built that business up for
the last three and a half years
and ended up selling it
about six months ago.
When I started the business, I
was just all (mumbles) speed.
What works, what doesn't.
So we did a lot of like A/B testing.
We tried direct marketing, direct sales
and I have a sales background.
We tried a variety of different things,
- What were you selling?
- It was a virtual
reality events business.
We did B2B events, like conferences,
things of that nature.
One of those things that
we did like A/B testing for
was just generally social media.
Hindsight, that's probably
something stupid to cut.
But basically we saw so
much success in other areas
that we just decided
social media is not for us.
We were starting to,
- Because social media by nature
is branding and marketing and sales
and most people are
looking for sales at first.
It's a complete ROI math arbitrage.
It's the last call.
The reason I'm different than most people
is I actually know how to build Nike,
not how to sell 30,000 pairs of sneakers.
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah, I completely agree.
I've been listening to you
for three or four years.
Honestly, I started listening
right when I started that job.
And I keep listening to you because,
I know social media guys
(mumbles) obviously,
especially in the longterm.
But what I really like
listening to you about
is your passion, your authenticity.
Everything about like knowing who you are.
So that's a lot of what
I've been absorbing.
I sold my business about six months ago
because I had more or less,
not a change in passion.
I was never passionate
about that business,
- It was just time.
- I wanted to start doing
something I was passionate about.
- Good for you.
- I sold that and now I
started a new business,
which we just launched a few weeks ago.
It's sun protective apparel.
- I love that.
I had a few changes in my life last year
where I got married.
So that was a big life change.
- Congratulations.
- But then I was also diagnosed
with melanoma skin cancer
which fortunately was removed.
But I'm athletic, I did
college track and field.
I'm a CrossFit coach, big
into the fitness community.
I'm always outdoors working out.
And there was no shirts
that could actually protect me from UV.
That was like the market need I found.
I'm launching my own product.
- There's no better business on earth
than when someone
scratches their own itch.
- Yeah.
- That's my favorite,
literally my favorite.
way of business starts.
Literally my favorite.
Number one, number one.
- Yeah, that's a big reason I started it
because of listening to your content
and hearing that over and over and over.
It's like, what is my need?
What exists in the marketplace
or what doesn't exist in the marketplace
that I can that need?
I jumped in, started it.
So I have a fresh slate again.
Didn't do any social media last business.
Personally, I do little
to no like social media.
I don't have like a personal brand.
I use social media strategically
to reach out decision makers on Instagram,
use that messaging sphere, use Twitter
but I don't have any personal preference.
- And one thing I'm worried
about if you're using that,
are using it from your personal account
or your brand's account?
- In the past I've used it
from my brand's account.
- One of the things that
you need to keep in mind
is how good that brand
or the person shows up,
is a big factor in the
conversion of that outreach.
A highly attractive person, boy or a girl,
is more likely to get the
person they're courting
when they're out that they think is cute
than one that's not.
Same with social.
If your shit is good and
social when you reach out,
good things happen at a higher percentage.
'Cause you've got sale, you're
a salesman, which I love.
I am too, I get it.
You've got that part down.
You can be very effective with this,
when you start reaching out to
influencers or other people,
if your brands showing up proper,
when they look at who DM them,
they're more likely to
do something with you
at a better cost, whether
that's free or a discount.
If you look like shit
or if you're not playing the game right,
they're gonna charge you twice.
You can see how the economics
amortize out very quickly.
Sure, because you're a sales brain,
you already can see why just
gave you a very good reason
that your Instagram and
Pinterest and Tik Tok
need to look proper just on the arb,
on the transactional
influencer marketing play.
- That's actually ultimately
the question I had for you.
Basically I have two blind slates.
I have my business, I have my personal.
I want to deliver all the content.
- Both.
- So is it more effective
to do four hours every
single day of my business
or like two and two.
Let's say I only have four hours,
- Why do you only have four hours?
Help us with that part,
we'll get to other part.
- It could change day by day.
I'm starting a new apparel business.
Just the process of getting
operations set up, sales,
- I see, I see.
You're talking about
four hours of marketing,
not four hours a day.
- Four hours is available
to dedicate to marketing and (mumbles).
- That's amazing.
First of all, that's amazing.
You went from putting me in a bad mood
to a great mood.
(Devin laughs)
You know what I would do?
Not overthink it, go with the flow.
Being a personal brand is tricky,
it might not be in your DNA.
You might be self conscious.
You're like, "what do I fucking say?"
Please look into the the
content pyramid I put out
and watch the video of
The Document Don't Create.
Get that into your brain.
Here's the answer.
One day, 30 minutes personal brand,
three and a half hours brand.
Five days in a row, four
hours personal brand.
People think there's a
blueprint, there isn't.
It's a net-net game.
I want you to taste both at enough scale
that one or two emerge.
But look, a cancer survivor
is inspirational, period.
That is an emotionally,
like fuck man.
And you can help a lot of
people, fuck selling shit.
Like you're gonna help some kids.
You're gonna help a 16 year old.
- It's bigger than me.
- It is bigger than you.
You've gotta do the personal brand.
But the apparel brand
will be able to scale you
when you hire two people.
So the answer is both.
Both, both, both, both.
And don't over judge yourself
on the strategy up front.
There is no right answer.
Just let it flow.
Whatever your fucking
feeling, let it flow.
And when you don't feel it,
just like you didn't feel the
fucking VR business anymore,
switch it.
You get a little burnt
out of doing personal shit
and you go hard, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom.
That's why I love having a ton of shit.
Sometimes I'm flowing on Empathy wines.
Sometimes I'm flowing in WineText,
sometimes I'm slow in Vayner
and then VaynerX has like
fucking launched (mumbles).
I just can't stop launching businesses
'cause I need flow.
- Congrats on VaynerCommerce by the way.
I was reading more about that yesterday.
It's awesome.
- Thank you.
All right bro, wish you well.
I appreciate you, thanks.
- Take care Devin.
Flow.
Flow, flow, flow.
It's really cool, really cool business.
I like where he's going,
I'm really rooting for him.
And the Saints signed Juwan Johnson,
one of our VaynerSports most
exciting rookies this year.
That's (mumbles) over there?
A little slow on the trigger.
- I always like to wait til
you're finished your sentence.
- Thank you, sir.
Thank you, I'm ready.
- Hi.
- Hi Mary Anne.
- I met you in 2009 and I apologize
'cause it took me way too
long to listen to you.
- Well listen, I'm glad you're here.
- Thank you.
I've been going through Jab Jab Jab.
Right hook on the southpaw,
so I guess for me it's really leftover.
I understand on page 13,
you talk about that magic blueprint
that everybody wants to know
when it's time for the right hook.
I understand that that doesn't exist.
My question is, what are the
indicators that you look for
of knowing when it's
time to throw that hook?
- It's less about the
indicators from the audience.
It's more about the
indicators in my real life.
Like when Empathy Wines
was done being made
and it was time to sell.
It was time to throw the
right hook and announce it.
When WineText was invented,
then went three months and
I felt it was perfected,
then it was the time to right hook.
So it's less about you feel
like your audience is there,
it's more about the necessity
to throw the right hook.
There's never a bad time
to throw a right hook.
There's, I have a preference
that the longer you can build trust,
that your hook will land more likely.
Because most people, and you know this,
are throwing right hooks from day one.
- Yeah.
- But I would say that
the indicator to when
is more predicated on the business.
Whether it's a financial need.
There's some people that need
to throw right hooks right now
that didn't want to.
But their business is
struggling in a COVID world.
I think the right hook
is predicated more on your business truth,
your need for dollars.
The longer you don't need dollars,
just like that young woman,
a couple of questions ago.
If you don't have to monetize
your audience, don't.
If I lost all my businesses,
maybe Tea with GaryVee would
just be a subscription business
'cause I'll need to feed my family.
But I prefer not to throw the right hook.
And when I throw right hooks,
I try to make them not direct
to what I do for a living.
I like that my right hooks
are like sneakers and wine
more than more than
paywalls behind content
because I've established that
as a free part of my life.
- I have a brick and mortar
and I'm working on pivoting
to your model of free
content to paid access.
- Yes, I love that.
Do me a favor, Mary Anne,
when you go to that,
make sure when you're in your free world,
that you're reading.
Just flirting just to the last part
and then you gotta pay.
What I think it really requires,
it's kinda how I think about nonprofit.
I don't start businesses that have like,
if you buy Empathy, we donate $5 to,
I don't like mixing.
I like doing my thing and
then quietly behind the scenes
doing the right thing in my give back.
I like that separation.
Similar to the young men
that started the show,
divide and conquer.
When people blend stuff,
they tend to get caught.
If you're a strategy
goddess, which I love,
do me a favor, really
give everybody your best.
Know this, the information's a commodity.
There's nothing I don't say publicly
that I say to my clients.
It's the nuances of the
details and the execution.
Most people that want to sell content
think that they have
to hold something back
that they don't hear in the
free part, it's not true.
You're selling the access, the one on one.
Where I can ask an extra question.
When you can ask the next question.
That's why this has been so powerful
in comparison to my QA shows.
I've had time to go deeper.
I was over with 20 minutes
yesterday with that guy.
It's the depth, that should liberate you
to give better information for free
'cause you know you're
selling access and nuances,
not information.
- Okay.
- Understand?
- Yeah, the access is where it gets
what I would call into a
real custom kind of program.
- And you can do custom in a lot of ways.
You can have a scaled 50 person group
that all pay one thing.
You can have it tiered
even in the pay part.
You can have up to 100 people
paying 100 bucks a month
and then you can have $1000 thing
'cause it's one-on-one for hours.
More access, more valuable.
- Any other advice about having
like a really big vision?
'Cause I know you have your
vision about buying the jets.
Mine's pretty big.
- Go ahead, what is it?
- I wanna end violence
against women and children.
- I think when you have
such an altruistic,
it's funny, I have a secret bigger mission
than the jets thing,
which is I wanna reframe
alpha male success
to be around kindness and empathy.
I think (mumbles) you have to realize,
you have no shot of accomplishing it
before your death when it's that big.
When you're boiling the ocean,
you need to enjoy the process
and you need to know that
you're just one tiny block
in the building towards
it and you try to strive
to be the best possible block you can be.
I think when people have big
goals, they get crippled by it
and then they really just
get into this mucky place.
I think you just need to be practical
about how big of a goal that is
and you need to push hard every day.
Every day I push hard through
my private and public actions
to put kindness and empathy and compassion
and sympathy and warmth on a pedestal.
And that's all you can do.
- There was one of my favorite moments,
I think it was two weeks
ago of you and your dad,
where he just grabbed your face
and planted this kiss on you.
I was just in tears.
It was so beautiful to see that.
- Nicest good, we need so much more light.
Negativity unfortunately, is
much louder than positivity.
That's why people are so stressed
and caught up in what social media does.
'Cause social media it's just an exposer,
an indicator, a mirror
to who we actually are.
It doesn't change us, it's exposing us.
If you have good in your soul,
I feel like it's a huge requirement
to share it and talk about it.
- Thank you.
And thank you for demonstrating
that kind of emotional range.
We need more men like you
out there demonstrating that.
Thank you for being that man.
- I'm on it.
You're welcome.
Take care Mary Anne, bye bye.
- Bye.
- Alright, keep this going.
Curtis.
- Hey Gary.
How are you?
- You hear me?
I can.
- Good, really good.
This is super exciting, holy shit.
I'll just give you a
little bit of context.
I have like two questions,
one's a little bit more heady,
one's a little bit more tactical.
Just to bring some value
and then kinda explain all this.
I moved out, I fucking
don't rely on my parents
as much anymore.
I traded my car and I don't
drive like a fancy car anymore.
- Why did that happen?
- My dad bought the car and
he kinda values that stuff.
And I understand he comes
from that generation.
- Why did you decide that?
- I was trying to cut costs.
I'm trying to live humble.
I do.
- I'm doing that.
- Why?
Did somebody tell you
my content, something?
Why?
- A big insecurity I've always had
was relying on my parents.
When he bought the car, it's
like, fuck, I didn't do that.
You know what I mean?
- So you were always there mentally.
You always had a discomfort
with that relationship.
- 100%.
- Keep going.
- I worked that like shitty
job that you talk about
where I get to have all this time
to do the stuff that I wanna do,
but I get the job done.
I live in this humble apartment
and the biggest thing is I
stopped valuing perfection
to when I started putting content out.
If you look at some of
the stuff on my Instagram,
I'm literally in my girlfriend,
- What's your Instagram?
- @curt_dc.
Like kickboxing videos,
and I'm literally in my girlfriend's room
and there's like stuff on the floor.
I don't give a shit.
- Love it, love it.
Bro, so far you're firing me up,
like everything coming out of your mouth,
I'm fucking loving.
- Not bad, I've been
following you for so long.
But first question's a little heady
and the second question is
a little bit more tactical.
- I got it, I got that part.
- The first one is,
I've been putting content
out for a while now
and I believe that it is
in my best vested interest
to have everybody know
who I am, like you say.
And so I'm trying to
capitalize on that opportunity.
And the second reason is,
I just really want people
to have that winning mentality
'cause there's so many people around me,
they're in like shitty situations
and like a sports analogy
is if you're like down on these points,
your goalie is injured, all these excuses.
I understand you could fold, I understand.
It's totally understandable you could fold
but I just don't want that for them.
I want them to win.
I want them to have that
winning mentality that you have.
I've lived a pretty privileged life myself
and I'm only 27 so I don't
feel 100% comfortable
putting that out.
When I talk to them it goes over (mumbles)
- But I think you should
put out the content
because you come from an incredible place.
You are coming from a privileged place
and you're speaking at it.
You're gonna be able to hit people
that I'm not able to hit
because they can't associate.
You now have more credibility
with somebody who was wildly
entitled and privileged
and then you made the move.
I talk about making the move
'cause I've seen it
brings so much happiness
to people in that situation.
You've actually done it.
You have more legs to
stand on talking about it
at some level than I do
or at least from a different perspective.
- For example, there's one
guy who was talking to,
I'm glad he's actually
pretty responsive to you,
but he's divorced and he's got all these
financial pressure and stuff.
And I'm like, "Dude, why don't
you just like sell your house
and fucking do that stuff?"
He responded really well.
But I just feel like if I put content out,
I've never bought a house.
I don't know if that's,
- Bro, I never was a spoiled kid.
Bill Belichick was not
a good football player.
I think you speak to it from
your perspective about it.
- Okay.
- I speak on two core things,
things I've lived, which is
where I really spend my pocket.
But then things that have
become very obvious to me
as a human observer.
I'm good at that.
I understand that.
I feel comfortable with
what I'm talking about.
I have 100s and 100s and
100s of 1000s of interactions
with human beings that
made me very confident.
I think you're very confident in knowing
that that person would be much happier
if he minimalized and was able to breathe.
- And so you think it's okay
to put content out talking about that?
- As long as you're not full of shit.
I don't think you are.
I don't think you're gonna, pretend.
I think you're trynna help.
- Okay.
- I think you have a
very unique perspective.
Not only were you privileged
I assume that also meant
that you were around
other privileged people
and you've seen patterns.
You saw it while I was on
with Jared a little while ago.
I'm like, "Hey, don't
put me on a pedestal."
All you have to do is
just be humble about it.
I talk with such
conviction and so (mumbles)
and so much energy and so much confidence
that people often don't like me at first
or think I'm audacious
or think I'm full of shit
or think that I'm audacious.
And I understand.
When you come with this kind of heat,
they can come off that way.
But if you really watch carefully,
what makes me palpable is humility.
Just be humble about it.
- And then the second question is like,
I have all your books right in crushing it
and all that stuff.
I'm trying to think of brainstorm ways
to maybe make like a
little bit more money.
Like I said, I'm living super humbly.
But just to make like
maybe 500 to like a grand.
- I want you to make $30 million a second.
If you earned it yourself,
let's not demonize money.
Let's just demonize, being entitled to it
or being subsidized by somebody else
'cause it leads to unhappiness.
Not 'cause we're jealous of those people.
I think you should make as
much money as humanly possible.
Let's not demonize it.
If you earn it, that's
a great accomplishment.
- For sure, for sure.
I have all these hobbies,
like I'd build model kids,
I like do kickboxing,
like here's the Gundam,
I don't know if that's cool.
I've been going off on like
all my hobbies and stuff
I just thinking like
if I could brainstorm.
- Curt, listen, you're
uncomfortably likable.
Thanks.
- You're welcome.
I think you have a real shot.
What I would do if I were you
based on what I've just heard.
If you're a fucking kick boxer dude
and you got this great hair
and you fucking make
models and nerded out,
I think you need to put your
whole fucking world out there.
- I'm trying man.
- Good.
You're putting all this
stuff you're doing.
Are you putting in your
content the model stuff too?
- Yeah.
- Good.
I think you keep doing that at volume.
How hard are you going at Tik Tok?
- Not that much.
Like a little bit, a tiny bit.
- Yeah dude, I can even tell
you got some muscles underneath there.
Do some kickboxing fucking shit
with no shirt on and
you'll fucking growing,
- I've been doing a little bit.
- Bro, you need to post on
Tik Tok three times a day.
- Okay.
- If you want a prescription
from the doctor, here you go,
three times a day, Tik Tok, three.
- Okay.
Is a hobby shop still like viable?
'Cause I don't own the
intellectual property
obviously of the models.
- Of course not but you can
make models and sell them.
You can create your own model.
I don't think a hobby shop
is where you need to go
at this minimal level
because retail is not the place to go
especially if you don't have
the money to throw at it.
No.
You just watched a girl
three fucking videos ago,
fucking make art on jackets
and then make one Tik Tok
and explode her business.
- True.
- I think you should make a Shopify store
or make an Instagram.
There's a retro vintage toy guy
who just posts his toys
on fucking Instagram
and says $13 first person (mumbles)
So you know what to do.
Bro, I'm telling you, shirtless kickboxing
kiltmaking on Tik Tok will
change your life, three a day.
I'm telling you right now.
I own zero equity in Tik Tok.
I don't give a fuck about Tik Tok.
if Tik Tok disappears tomorrow,
you know me, you've been around.
I don't give a fuck.
I give a fuck about attention
when it's under priced
that can lead to something
that brings you happiness.
You know me, I can tell you know me
and you are making three tech
talks a day, fuck that bro.
I love everything about
you except that part.
- No, 100% I agree.
I don't like that part, I gotta do it.
- Dustin, what do you want?
- I'll just leave.
- You're not going anywhere.
- (mumbles) or sick by the way.
I looked at his Instagram,
your fucking (mumbles) are sick dude.
Why did you put that shit up?
That (mumbles) holy fuck.
- No, but I just wanted to say,
I didn't even know Curt
was gonna be on today
and he never asked me,
"Can I be on the show?"
But I noticed him
following me the other day
and I just like something I saw in his,
I just like his page
and I was like, I'm
going to follow him back.
- Is it because you're both
very handsome Asian men?
Are we going kinda like some culture here?
Like what do (mumbles).
Dustin super sneaky guys.
I think Dustin's gotta little
handsome thing going on.
Like right now, you got
this little like fucking
BMX shit going on like Dustin.
I've definitely gained
more attraction towards you
during this Tea Time.
- Thanks, right back at you.
- Thank you bro.
Is the beard,
Anyway, Curt, if you don't
make three posts a day,
I'm done with you.
- Yeah, I know for sure.
I get it.
- Is there a way I can come
hang out with you guys?
Yes.
- More like a date.
Yup.
- Really?
- Work with Dustin we
can have a triple date.
- That's awesome.
Thank you so much, I love you man.
- See you later, I love you man.
Dustin, do not let that
dude come to our office
unless he's posting three
times a day on Tik Tok.
- I will be creepy and make sure.
- Thank you.
Alright everybody, thank
you so much for watching.
Please sign up for WineText.
Please go to all in challenge.
Buy your raffle tickets,
my raffle's expiring soon.
I'm really looking forward
to spending the entire year
with somebody.
Let's talk soon, I love you guys, See ya.
I am giving away the
ultimate GaryVee experience.
How should I go?
(air whooshing)
Over the last week or so,
I've been jammin' with
my friend Michael Rubin
and helping out on this All in Challenge
that I am accepting right now.
But allinchallenged.com please go there.
We are challenging some
of the greatest artists,
entertainers, athletes in the world
to provide a ridiculous
all time experience
or one of their most iconic
items in their collection
to help raise money to
help feed the hungry
during this ridiculous time.
Now I have to put up my auction.
So my auction, the ultimate
GaryVee experience.
Here we go, I'm gonna go
off the top of the head
and you can go on allinchallenged.com
to go bid on this.
I am giving away,
you get to, in the course of a year,
you will go garage sailing with me
and film trash Trash Talk.
Also, you can get a workout
with me and Mike Vacanti.
I know a lot of you pay attention
to that part of my world.
Also we're gonna go to Wine Library
and do a $25,000 shopping spree.
That's right, I'm gonna pay my dad.
I'm gonna donate, we're
gonna pay my dad 25,000.
So $25,000 shopping spree at Wine Library.
I will walk through the
whole store with you,
tell you the war stories.
And you'll buy a bunch
of a wine, beer, liquor
whatever you want, food.
We are gonna go to a Jets game together.
You're gonna tailgate with me.
I never do this.
When I give away Jets tickets,
I never let the person sit with me.
You will sit with me during the Jets game.
I won't talk to you during the game.
I'm completely focused
but you'll get that.
The ultimate Jets experience,
tailgate full game with me as well.
Also, I'm going to give you
one week play at VaynerMedia.
This is for you and a
plus one, by the way.
The two tickets, we'll do some plus ones.
We'll do some just me and
you depending on what it is.
One full week at VaynerMedia
getting consulting and business advice
from team GaryVee and
me for the entire week.
Hanging out in the pit
where the show's done.
You're gonna be a guest of my podcast.
We're gonna do a wine dinner for you
and seven of your friends
at Hunt Fish & Club, New York city.
And I'm gonna fly you, all paid, plus one,
to three of my keynotes and
we'll work on those details.
The ultimate GaryVee experience.
I hope you bid on it, I
hope you get involved,
I hope we raise a lot of money
to help people that need it.
Also, what's so fun
about the Al-in Challenge
is you get to challenge
people to be in it.
I am gonna all the VaynerSports athletes.
I expect you in there.
That is number one.
Number two, I'm gonna go with,
you know what, Timbaland,
the super producer
who's completely lighting up Instagram.
Timbarland, the super
producer, I'm calling you out.
And finally, I got one,
The Undertaker.
One of the great wrestlers of all time.
Please join the challenge,
everybody go to allinchallenge.com.
Please support this, the
experiences are gonna be nuts.
We've been working bleeding
out of the eyeballs
for the last week,
putting this all together.
You're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see on social media
#allinchallenge.
Please check it out and please go
to your favorite celebrities,
athletes, and entertainers,
and leave #allinchallenge
to get them involved.
The All-in Challenge, please take it.